welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and the latest trailer for zack
snyder's justice league gives us an even
deeper look into snyder's original
vision including darkseid with dazad and
granny goodness
and jared leto joker hilariously
self-aware of his own meme culture
pretty much every shot in this has
little details added by snyder hinting
at how this r-rated recut on hbo max is
a
very different movie so let's break down
everything you might have missed from
this trailer let's get started
[Music]
okay this is a new angle of superman's
death with doomsday and batman v
superman his suit
visibly torn through the crest to
emphasize that there should be no way he
just puts on the same old blue and red
suit he's gotta go dark
kal-el's death screams have been
visualized as these
shockwave blasts representing the bell
that has been rung for darkseid
described by the voice of lex luthor
coming back from the end of batman v
superman and his warning to batman but
what i love about this if you were to go
back and watch batman v
superman back then snyder snuck in these
same vocal blasts
right as superman screamed in that scene
so this is what snyder is talking about
when he says
restoration he's not adding a bunch of
random stuff he's restoring
unappreciated details that were part of
his vision to begin with
and now by revisiting this moment in
snyder's slo-mo
we get to better observe the exact
consequences of kal-el's death
next clip
out in the dark
among the stars
[Music]
the god is dead okay here we follow the
death scream shockwave up through the
damaged city out into
the darkness where it can be picked up
by all kinds of evil [ __ ] i love how the
sound design just keeps that scream just
as powerful as it echoes outward
constant cry that never ends i know
that's how sound waves work shut up it's
just meaningful when it's pain
now of course superman's super breath is
one of his abilities it creates strong
gusts of wind you'll notice how it pans
the flames it crosses it blows back the
smoke but here it's not just a goofy
thing he's doing it's something he is
releasing
in his final breath and here is a good
example of why snyder reconceived this
all in the taller 1.43 to 1 aspect ratio
and the more common wider cinematic
aspect ratios of 1.85 to 1 or
nine to one action can only be shown
like right to left or left to right
across a
horizontal horizon but snyder felt that
cinema based on the comic book medium
a lot of action moves up and down like a
superhero taking off in flight a super
villain slamming
down his weapon or in this case this
sound wave
blasting outward away from us out into
the dark horizon and then we see the
shot of the themyscira temple crumbling
into the sea
presumably after steppenwolf's attack
and capture of that mother box
moving on i had a dream
almost like a premonition
i think there's an attack coming okay
some new shots of the post-apocalyptic
nightmare future from batman v superman
that this movie is revisiting bruce
describes it as a dream
premonition of an attack leaked
storyboard suggested this would be
five years into the future and now
instead of the dream it was depicted as
bvs it will be a true flash forward that
bruce will spend a lot more time
in maybe an actual future that the flash
will have to time travel back from
diana recovers the arrow that was fired
into this other temple at the moment of
steppenwolf's arrival and here she finds
this inner
chamber with art depicting the ancient
war against dark side the first time he
came
underneath dark side you can see a
depiction of the three mother boxes
merging together into the unity but
behind diana are depictions of the three
mother boxes separate
showing how those united forces of earth
once stopped that invasion but then a
shot of dark side marching past hundreds
of parademons in this classically
designed hall
draped with banners showing darkseid's
omega symbol in other shots darkseid is
really only seen in earth in ancient
times but
based on that rex skyscraper background
i believe this
is the same nightmare feature that
batman is in dark side is flanked by his
minions decide and the female to the
right is granny goodness confirmed by
zack snyder granny goodness
is one of darkseid's cruelest
lieutenants first she started out as one
of the lowly's of apocalypse trained up
into one of darkseid's hounds his
soldiers she was ordered to kill her dog
mercy that she had trained as part of
her training but she refused and then
she killed her trainer instead granny
goodness later ran the orphanage
training facility for all of darkseid
soldiers assuming this
is earth's future granny goodness could
be training all these parademons
formerly the soldiers of earth that have
been transformed
moving on this wall will fall
[Music]
i need warriors i'm building an alliance
to defend ourselves so here steppenwolf
kneels before a projection of
decide i love how sparks just rain down
from the projection like when you call
someone across the galaxy energy spills
all over the place makes a mess now you
may remember from the theatrical cut
this was the scene where steppenwolf
weirdly
praised and then we're just kind of left
even more confused as to what his
motives were
here this has been revised to clarify
the context of steppenwolf being
a cast out lieutenant of darkseid trying
to get back in darkseid's good graces
by recovering these three mother boxes
that were lost in the past war
this is gonna be the moment he says the
line no protectors here no lanterns no
kryptonian
this world will fall like all the others
and we see how
under his spiky armor steppenwolf's head
is truly otherworldly it's got
scaly skin hammerhead horns traps like
[ __ ]
meat sails this guy is fierce actually
compare his fight with the amazonians to
the theatrical cut
when the axe comes down before it barely
left a dent in the earth just kind of a
cgi slash
now it cracks the hell out of it it
sends chunks of terrain flying
you can feel that impact and then his
lightning charge swing releases
either dirt from the ground that he just
dug into or blood from that amazonian
rider either way
i love that debris then diana saves
these hostages though there is this
exterior shot of an explosion coming
from within the building
so i don't know in this version diana
might not cleanly detonate the suitcase
bomb
safely above the building and then
before we move on a shot of cyborg
no way does this guy have enough guns
based on his surroundings he looks like
he is
in that post-apocalyptic nightmare with
bruce and notice how he's got this third
appendage
toting a briefcase i thought maybe it
could have been connected to that fake
lexcorp suitcase from that nightmare
sequence in bbs though i think this
might be something for a deal they're
about to make with
the joker more on that later let's move
on
how do you know your team's strong
enough
if you can't bring down the charging
bull then don't wave the red cape at it
i love alfred's line here how it syncs
with the imagery if you can't bring down
the
charging bull right as steppenwolf
charges forward with his bull horns
and don't wave the red cape as cyborg
projects a hologram of superman with his
billowing red cape there's kind of a
message created here with the editing if
you can't defeat steppenwolf on your own
without resurrecting superman maybe you
shouldn't risk the temptation
of dancing with that red cape and you'll
notice steppenwolf's eyes glow
blue here unlike the white they glowed
in the theatrical cut may be suggesting
a link with the
unity or the blue boom tube portal that
has opened up
and then the imagery you've seen of dark
side in the ancient war but we see the
other shot of his axe terraforming this
whole plane creating this symbol out of
lava marking his territory i know this
is kind of hard to see it looks blurry
as if you're wearing someone else's
prescription glasses
by the way have you ever done that it
hurts your vision because they were not
meant for you and while we're on that
subject
quit sleeping on a mattress that isn't
meant for you either get yourself a
personalized helix mattress
helix mattresses are made in america and
shipped to your door with free delivery
free returns in a 100 night sleep trial
to choose a mattress helix made the
sleep quiz that takes just two minutes
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences
to the perfect mattress for you if you
like a mattress that's really soft or
really firm if you sleep on your side or
on your back or on your stomach or if
you tend to sleep
really really hot with helix there's a
specific mattress for each and
everyone's unique taste i took that quiz
i got matched with the
dusk looks helix mattress because i
wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support
that sleeps nice and cool i have been
sleeping great ever since i got it helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress
pick of 2020 by gq wired magazine and
apartment therapy
go to helixsleep.com rockstars take
their two minute sleep quiz
and they will match you to your
customized mattress for the best sleep
of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll even pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
you will
helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners
at helixsleep.com rockstars that is
sleep.com rockstars for up to 200
off into free pillows moving on
you're sitting here for a reason
and even if it takes you the rest of
your life
find out what that reason is
okay i love this this new shot of victor
stone in his number seven gcu letterman
jacket on this
interesting landscape this probably
synced with that other reverse shot
we've seen
of cyborg in this form stopping the
artillery which means it must be inside
his mind and i love it rather than
cyborg just plugging into a machine we
get to see how his fusion with
technology looks
in his own mind's eye and then more of
the scene when barry allen saves iris
west from her car collision with the hot
dog cart
this cart looks like a farm produce got
this fox logo maybe connected to the
family of lucious fox maybe not i do
love how the
ketchup and the mustard snake out of
their squeeze bottles
all these little pieces of food just to
show us how barry is moving at god level
speed i love debris
and then this shot of superman in his
black suit clenching his fist as pebbles
float off the ground clearly we are
getting a man of steel flight sequence
2.0
bringing him full circle with his first
flight from that kryptonian ship
nice moving
[Music]
[Applause]
they on the age of heroes would never
come again
okay in this section there's this
interesting shot of batman on this
bat tank this is what snyder is calling
batman's war machine
you know that's something in a different
universe anyway it appears to be based
on the tank from frank miller's the dark
knight returns looks as though batman
could be using this to help clear the
rubble
in the aftermath of the death of
superman but another interesting shot
cyborg trying to looks like separate the
mother boxes from the unity but now
the flash appears behind him speed force
ignited
to what interfere with this and then
there's this curious look of recognition
washing over victor's face as the camera
pushes into his eye so what is going on
here
well it is almost certain at this point
that the snyder cut is going to
partially set
up the flash movie itself an adaptation
of the flashpoint paradox in which barry
allen
sprints through time and picks up all
the timelines so here we could be seen
in which barry returns to this moment
from the future to stop
cyborg from meddling with the unity
because it could have some unintended
consequences
because check it out as barry sprints
the other shot it almost looks like he's
running into an explosion as it's being
reversed
crumbling debris rolling back into place
so folks anyone who says zack snyder's
justice league is just going to be a
prettier glossier version of the
theatrical cut
hold the hell up we could totally see
the justice league
fail leading to the post-apocalyptic
nightmare future
a future from which barry has to go back
in time to reverse the events that led
to it that's probably what barry was
doing in that scene in batman v superman
where he's like am i too soon and we
could see this whole history play out a
second time differently that's how you
get a four hour movie and could all set
up a butterfly effect crisis with
reverse flash that barry could have to
deal with in the flashpoint movie moving
on to the next clip
i will has to
okay i cannot get enough of this shot of
superman black suit heat vision blasting
downward presumably at steppenwolf
look behind him yeah i think that blue
portal is the boom tube
opened up by the motherbox unity to
darkseid in his parademon army on
apocalypse on the other side
one of zack snyder's many described
visuals was for steppenwolf's severed
head
to roll down this boom tube and stop at
the feet of darkseid
i am praying to leonard cohen that we
get that here yeah let's move on to the
big hunka hunka in the final clip
we live in a society where honor
is a distant memory isn't that right
batman okay so you may have seen my
mental breakdown in yesterday's reaction
but just to elaborate zack snyder
revealed that he brought back jared leto
joker from suicide squad as one of his
few
major changes that he added in
retrospect that even though jared leto
joker was
not in his script for justice league it
was part of his overall vision for the
dceu to have him and ben affleck batman
meet and we know the timeline of this
edition based off how joker quotes the
we live in a society meme this is where
folks would start
to use heath ledger's nihilist joker to
make memes for their awful
philosophical hot takes which of course
evolved into later parodies of that
using in addition to heath ledger joker
jared leto joker walking phoenix joker
we live in a society is just kind of a
joke
about people who think they're being
profound and saying something no one
stopped before when that's obviously
[ __ ] so why does he quote it here
well think about this joker this joker
had a bunch of tattoos that were
explained to be
sort of part of a punk commentary on
general
joker pop culture so we live in a
society
is kind of on game for that meta concept
of the character but his tattoos are
gone now
it does look like he might have covered
them with makeup
sloppily smeared on mouth covered like a
kid who ate a whole bag of cheese puffs
and greasy hair
it's all a bit similar to the heath
ledger grunge diy take on the character
snyder has described this version of the
character as a more world weary joker a
quote ghost of christmas yet to come and
his meeting with batman here is meant to
put batman on blast for all of his past
choices that led to this
joker says honor is a distant memory
suggesting that batman has devolved into
a hero without honor without rules one
who takes lives that line that he had
previously avoided crossing but now has
to do all the time
making him a lot more like the honorless
joker
but the way leto talks is weird here
notice how he pronounces
distant it's a distant memory yeah
distant
almost as if his teeth have been knocked
out right he did have that grill before
maybe
batman an active rage caved his mouth in
now remember batman had a
joker card taped to his gun in that
nightmare sequence we saw that same card
floating past camera in past
trailers and now snyder intends to
explain the story behind that
joker here wears a swat vest that snyder
says is adorned with police badges
like trophies now this swat vest could
be connected to the swat gear he wore
when he rescued harley quinn in the
final scene of suicide squad but
underneath it he wears a butcher apron i
don't know maybe he thinks of himself as
a butcher of
pigs now snyder says that had the studio
allowed him to do another movie he would
have wanted to explore batman's past
with joker how joker killed robin
leading to that hahaha jokes on you how
joker burned down wayne manor and even
though we might not see it hopefully
this dialogue between them will hint at
a lot of that dark history but you'll
notice behind batman is cyborg here and
it almost looks like he's wearing the
same hoodie he wore when he met diana so
i think his
and batman's mission is to connect with
joker to offer him
something because i think joker in this
post-apocalyptic aftermath of darkseid's
destruction
has been able to get his hands on mother
box tech and in order to do whatever
they gotta do they gotta make a deal
with this devil by the way if you wanna
continue this nerdy conversation new
rockstars has an amazing discord
community that you can join by becoming
a patron at patreon.com new rockstars
you can also support us in other ways
like checking out our great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars here on youtube hit that
notification bell thank you for watching
boom
[Music]
so
[Music]